Thank you for having me here at Google and for coming to my talk today.
Uh,
I'm a fan of many of the things that you're doing.
I'm a huge fan in particular because the company is data driven in many ways and
also in the ways that I particularly care about its work on diversity and
inclusion and generally in is talent management.
So with that kind of,
I hope this is going to resonate with you.
What I was trying to do with the book was really bringing data and evidence to
bear on a question on which many people are very passionate about and I shared a
passion.
But what I'm trying to argue is that we have to bring the same kind of rigor
that we use to analyze unemployment or inflation to questions of gender
equality.
So here's what I want to do,
what I want to start out by kind of talking a little bit about why we might want
to care.
Then I want to talk about what we're up against and I know you all are,
many of you have gone through unconscious bias training so you will be familiar
with much of that.
And then I want to spend most of the talk discussing how we can redesign our
organizations to level the playing field and making it easier for all of us to
do the right thing.
So some of you might be here because they care about um,
this pyramid here because you care about the absence of women in leadership.
And then some others might be here because you care about even bigger questions.
And I would actually suggest to you that this slide is a slide that you shoot
most care about even more so than the pyramid.
The UN in fact now estimates that about 200 million women and girls are missing
because of gender side gendercide because of sex,
selective abortion or neglect in the first five years.
Now this in itself,
of course it's tragedy,
but I'm starting with it because a problem that many thought was too difficult
to even address led to some really inspiring research.
A colleague of mine,
Rob Jansen,
who's now at Wharton,
went into India and exploded.
The fact that many call centers have morphed into India in the nineties and day
often hired women.
So what he did was he ran an experiment,
a field experiment where he had treatment villages and control villages and in
the treatment villages he offered service and changing for women to go and work
in call centers.
And yes,
he was interested in where did that would affect the likelihood that this women
would go and work in the call center.
But more importantly he was interested in where did this affect how parents
treat their zero to five year old daughters.
Do we even deported the deport care about returns on investment?
And that's what you found.
So he measured survival chances.
He measured body mass index.
He and his team,
of course,
he measured whether these girls said would be in school.
And we try to understand what a parents started to treat her daughters better
when there was a future for the daughters.
And that's what he found was a long experiment of over about 10 years.
And he could show that economic opportunity actually can change her parents
think about the value of having daughters without negatively affecting their
sons.
And I think that's why we should care.
We should really care because for some,
this quite literally is a matter of life and death.
But bringing you back to somebody who I think many of you know,
this is Heidi Roizen.
If you have gone through the unconscious bias training at Google,
you might have encountered her.
She is an entrepreneur,
a venture capitalist in Silicon Valley and she was famous before a case study
made her even more famous.
And the case study in an interesting way made her famous because some colleagues
of ours,
a Columbia business school use this case to teach their students about bias in
the moment.
How does this down now across really this country and some other schools around
the world is that half of the students would get the case of the protagonist
being called Howard and the other half would get the case with the protagonists,
having her real name,
Emily,
Heidi,
and then students read the case,
everything identical and then rape powered.
And Heidi and again you will have been there if you have done the training.
We generally do think that both Heidi and how do a good job and are competent,
but we do not like Heidi and do not want to hire Heidi because Heidi violates
gender norms.
That's what we're up against when we try to overcome some of these patterns that
affect our thinking.
But let me ask you to take a look at the pattern here that you see.
Why don't you compare squares a and B for me?
I presume most of you see square B as being lighter than square a.
It turns out that this is an illusion and what I'm going to do next is I'm going
to cover the surroundings here.
And I presume that most of you now see the squares as having identical color.
I'm going to go back just quickly because you look at me puzzled.
So here's what happened in your minds.
Your mind made immediately sent up the pattern that it saw a checkerboard and
your mind knows that the light square has to be next to a dark square and you
also take a bit the shadow into account to correct that shadow.
So the question being in front of us is the following.
What kind of patterns do we see in the world out there,
which keep us from seeing square B for what it really is.
Another dark square.
Okay,
so some creative interventions built quite directly on this,
and you might have heard of orchestras,
the larger orchestras in this country introducing blind auditions in the 70s
many major orchestras in the United States introduced the curtains and had the
musicians audition behind curtains that increased the likelihood that women
would be hired by 50% or put differently.
Blind auditions played a huge role and increasing the fraction of female
musicians from 5% to now almost 40% on the major orchestras in this country.
This is quite different from the roughly 10% female musicians,
for example,
in Berlin or under the end.
Now symphony.
So blind auditions are an attractive tool that in fact many organizations now
increasingly rely on.
Of course,
not in terms of auditions,
but in terms of blinding themselves to demographic characteristics of the top
applicants.
But I want to use the blindness primarily as a metaphor for us because what
we're trying to do here is really learned from these curtains for other types of
design interventions,
which could make it easier for all of our minds to get things right.
And that's where I want to take you today.
In fact,
before I talked about gender,
I want to leave you with another metaphor which surely must be familiar to many
of you.
Most of you must have been in a hotel room where the room key card did not only
serve the purpose to open and close the doors,
but also to turn lights on and off.
This is another little bit of technology a little bit of design would make,
which makes it easier for all of us who actually think that we care about the
environment to follow through and leave the room when the lights are off.
So that's where I'm going,
trying to make it easy for us to do the right thing.
And this,
of course,
it's very,
very different from other types of things that we have been doing and could be
doing.
It's different from diversity training,
not clearly diversity training is important for raising awareness,
but as we all know,
it is often hard to follow through because by definition these biases are
unconscious.
And even though I now realize that I will treat the male kindergarten teacher or
the male nurse differently from their steer typical counterparts who happened to
be women,
I can't guarantee that tomorrow when I see a male nurse,
I will object to fully evaluate that person.
Seeing really is believing.
So diversity turning is a start,
but I'm arguing that to be really advanced the needle and make a difference,
we have to go deeper and do more.
And yes,
trainings,
enabling traditionally disadvantaged groups to succeed have been shown to have
some impact.
But again,
I don't think the solution can be to fix women or people of color or other
underrepresented underrepresented groups,
but eventually we have to move to fixing the system.
So that's where I want to take you want to talk about three different topics
that I touched upon in the book.
The first one is time management.
Something that everyone in this room and everyone across the globe really,
uh,
that is listening to my talk today has been involved in in some form,
shape or form.
Either because you've interviewed for a job or because you were one of the
people evaluating others.
Then I want to talk a little bit about redesigning school and work and give you
some examples of how that might be done.
And then finally I'll talk about possibly the hardest topic and that is how to
design diversity,
how to make diversity really work.
Okay.
So any talent management of course starts by attracting the right kinds of
people.
And curiously enough,
we have been thinking about,
for example,
gendered advertisements for a very long time,
not as Coca Cola,
not just Pepsi.
Now,
not just other soft drink companies,
but all of us,
we are kind of aware of the fact that some colors,
for example,
some shapes,
some names appeal more to women than to men or vice versa.
In coax case,
it was their word,
diet coke and other soft drink companies realized that men don't seem to be
buying diet.
Coke of course,
could have lots of reasons.
Either men don't care about the calories they take or they don't have an issue
with calories.
I didn't run more along the Charles River or diet is not the word,
so they replaced diet by coke zero which was for men.
The Pepsi did the same thing.
Pepsi Maxi instead of Diet Pepsi and of course Gillette it to reverse when
introducing Venus,
Gillette,
that comes in colors that resonates to people like me in pink.
I argue that I want,
I don't want to defend this in any way,
I'm just describing that this is happening,
but what I do want to argue is that we should use the same kind of scrutiny in
our job advertisements.
So here is an APP that a school posted which wanted to increase the fraction of
its male teachers.
So probably know when the United States,
we now have about 10 to 15% male teachers in our elementary schools,
which increasingly poses a problem for our boys because they no longer have male
role models.
So this ad looked like this looking for a warm and caring teacher with
exceptional pedagogical and interpersonal skills to work in a supportive
collaborative work environment.
The adjectives that we highlighted of course are gendered and typically
associated with women.
And research suggests that this will in fact substantially decreased the
likelihood that men will apply to these jobs.
So an alternative ad could have looked something like this looking for an
excellent teacher with exceptional pedagogical skills.
Now of course the school might say,
but we really care about the caring
and if they do that is okay,
I'm not prescribing what schools or any organization for that matter should be
doing.
But what I am arguing is that we should do it consciously,
but we should understand what messages we send and send the messages that we do
want to send and that are important to us in a conscious way.
And that of course often means that we have to measure that.
We have to collect the data and evaluate the impact of what what we're doing.
Now,
let me move on to somewhat higher hanging fruit.
This is a hard one and I know Google and new people,
analytics groups have worried about this for quite a long time.
Of course what we're up against in evaluating people is that most of us believe
that we are particularly good interviewers and those of you who've read the book
by Laszlo Bock will recall that among all the Googlers there is this one outlier
who is an amazing interviewer and everyone else is just average and that's kind
of true for the world that we all think are very good and will feel whether you
belong or not,
when in fact what we're building our assessments on are the stereotypes and are
these implicit assumptions that we often even can't articulate.
In my case,
for example,
a real moment of a wake up call was when a job candidate is a real story,
a job candidate,
and I started to talk about the fact that we both had been synchronized swimmers
and I felt immediately that,
oh my God,
that will make her an amazing Harvard professor.
Now we can't keep that from happening at,
that's the problem of interviews.
It's not that everything's just bad,
but it's hard for us to distill the useful information from noise.
And so I have this summer cheesy stock photo up here to suggest to you that
almost everything that you see here is wrong.
So the first thing that is wrong is that we shouldn't do panel interviews.
We shouldn't do panel interviews because the sample size of a panel interview is
basically one d three people will not come up with independent assessments and
is of course much better to have three separate interviews with three separate
evaluations going on independently.
Is Second myth is that diversity on the evaluation committee itself will solve
our problems.
Now,
diversity can be helpful in that we might reach out to different networks and
invite different people to apply to the jobs,
but it doesn't protect us from implicit bias.
Seeing really is believing and if you don't see female engineers or male
kindergarten teachers,
we don't naturally associate those jobs with men or women respectively.
So diversity itself can be the solution.
Then thirdly,
and now of course I'm in,
um,
uh,
reading a bit much into this picture here.
What's really important is that we always try to calibrate our judgments but
forcing our minds to make comparisons.
So why am I saying this very basic insight in behavioral sciences that
everything that you judge,
everything that you evaluate the coffee that you now drink or the water that you
have in front of you has something to do with the kinds of coffees that you
normally drink.
That is your reference point of view,
reference coffee that helps you evaluate whether that's good or bad coffee.
Of course,
we do the very same thing when we evaluate people.
We tend to evaluate them compared to what we're used to in these specific
professions or jobs.
And so what we're trying to do is to overcome that need to rely on this internal
little reference person sitting in our head who looks like the stereotype.
And what we've been showing with a number of experiments is that when I forced
you to compare at least two,
probably more,
but at least two job candidates at the same time,
you will be able to overcome your stereotypes and are much more likely to focus
on these people's individual characteristics.
Um,
their ability,
what they bring to the table rather than the groups that they belong to.
So comparisons can be a powerful tool to calibrate your judgments.
All of this of course hints at the fact that what we really should do is use a
more structured process and it was very happy to learn that Google uses many of
these insights already in that you predetermined the questions that you want to
ask.
You ask all of your job candidates the same kinds of questions you asked in the
same order in ideally what we should also do as we should rate every question,
every answer that we get after we've asked the question.
And then move on to the next question so that we're not biased by whatever the
candidate responded to.
The first question that we asked,
there's a number of these tools that are discussed in the book and I'm actually
quite excited because there are now these startup companies using some of these
insights and translating them into the technology,
which will make it easier for all of us to use more structured approaches to our
hiring and evaluation processes.
But of course we have our insights shouldn't stop at the entry level and many of
you will argue going back to the pyramid that the really big challenges start
once you are in an organization.
Let me give you kind of three quick thoughts on the kind of things that we might
want to change their,
the first one is super trivial and I'm won't be one month strike you as
surprised at all and that is just measure the support that we give our employees
to help them succeed.
So just down the road here,
MIT was one of the first institutions whereas the first academic institutions I
should,
I should say actually measuring the support that people got and given that the
MIT of course the data spoke for itself.
They literally used a measuring rod to measure people's office spaces,
the laboratories that had available to support staff,
research assistance,
resource resources,
et Cetera,
and they found what then later was called performance support bias,
which disadvantage to women.
Now that of course again is low hanging fruit that we can fix right easily.
It gets a bit more complicated when we think about performance appraisals at
first.
Insight is that whenever I work with organizations I typically find by is not so
much when organizations evaluate the past performance,
which many organizations literally do on the x axis.
But typically when organizations also evaluate the potential because potential
by definition is forward looking and by definition is very hard to measure.
And that's where the high d bias,
the leadership bias kicks in because we cannot imagine that women or other
underrepresented groups who are not typically in the leadership positions would
want to climb up the career ladders.
So potential is certainly something that you should be worried about.
And if you want to use potential,
what I typically try to argue is we try,
we should try to define as precisely as you possibly can,
what we really need with potential and force ourselves to quantify it as much as
it possibly can.
And then thirdly and finally,
um,
we should stop sharing self evaluations of our managers.
Many organizations ask their employees to self evaluate themselves often on a
rating skills,
let's say from one to 10 and then asked the employees to share these evaluations
with their supervisors.
Now,
little bit of behavioral science already suggests to us that this will anchor
the manager's assessments because any numbers that I throw at you or whether in
a negotiation or in performance appraisal will affect your judgements.
And if people differ in their self confidence that will affect developed
evaluations they end up with.
These are just some ideas of how we can kind of fix and improve how we do our
talent management.
But let me go to some bigger questions.
And this one might resonate with you in particular.
Now I don't see too many people have recently taken the sat in this room,
but most of you will have taken it at some point.
And I remember that part of the sat is a multiple choice questionnaire.
Now think about the following thought experiment.
If in fact people differ in their willingness to take risk,
some people will be more willing to guess or volunteer an answer and others will
be more willing to skip the question.
So generally,
much,
much research suggests that women tend to be more risk averse than men and
former doctor schools,
doctoral student of mine,
Katie Baldyga Kaufman in fact took this to heart and wanted to check whether
that might cost the skippers points on the sat because they weren't willing to
guess.
So she brought a large number of subjects to the laboratory.
They participate in sat but only in the multiple choice part of the sat.
And then given that this was the laboratory,
she could force everyone to answer every question so she could take out the
skipping option and thereby measure what people would have known.
Happy,
answered all the questions.
And what she found that was that equally able people controlling for ability,
women are much more likely to skip and men are more likely to guess which costs
women do yearly on the sat.
Now,
the happy ending of the story is that this month,
last month,
it's already April,
March,
2016.
Um,
as you probably have read in the news,
the sat has been redesigned and one of the new design features is to [inaudible]
the sat to gender device.
Gsat really in many ways,
the first time in a hundred years,
the sat now is trying to provide a level playing field and it could have done
many different things.
The college board ended up choosing to take away the penalties for guessing
wrongly,
completely and the all the sat,
you got a point for every right answer and a quarter point deduction for wrong
answers.
So a little bit of math,
um,
suggested to people that if you hard five possible answers available,
you can exclude one than it is the dominant strategy to guests.
But if people differ in their willingness to take risk,
of course there is Glover's will be more likely to guests and the risk avoiders.
So the new tests takes the penalty completely away.
At which point the critiques of course said,
Oh my God,
you're an enabling guessing now and you're inviting wild guessing by everyone,
Eh,
at which point the answer must be,
well,
we have been inviting guessing by 50% of the population for about a hundred
years.
Now we're making it legal for everyone to do so.
So that's design.
Design can be powerful,
can really change.
How we do things and level the playing field quite dramatically.
Uh,
here's another example.
that can be quite powerful and that is literally the power of role models
leaving the u s for a moment because interestingly enough,
and unbeknownst to many people,
the longest run in quota experiment has in fact been run in India,
not in Norway or some other countries which recently have introduced quotas on
its corporate boards.
India men have this constitution,
1993 have to provision that a third,
a village heads had to be female us.
Beautiful from a research point of view.
The third was literally picked out of a hat allowing researchers to evaluate
what difference difference really makes and a number of papers have been written
in those 22 years roughly,
but the one that I want to particularly focus on here was recently published in
science suggesting that if a village has been exposed to two female leaders in
those 22 years,
mindsets are starting to change and parents and girls are starting to associate
political leadership with women.
That's pretty dramatic.
Again suggesting that seeing really is believing and that if we see counter
stereotypical people in those jobs,
we can actually imagine ourselves in those jobs.
And it has quite real implications.
So I'm sad to say this,
my own institution to Harvard Kennedy School,
that only 11 years ago we realized that all the portraits on our walls of
leaders were of men.
50% of our students are female.
And it wasn't our conscious intention to suggest to our female students that
they were not made to be leaders.
So we've changed that since this is Ellen Johnson Sirleaf the president of
Liberia,
also graduate after school.
We commissioned a portrait of hers,
Abigail Adams,
uh,
a number more to change the face quite literally of the Kennedy School and make
it a more inclusive environment.
Very serious research suggests that even what we see in our walls can affect our
beliefs.
And then of course there is some really happy news that,
uh,
recently we've had a female protagonist Rey in star wars.
And of course that does matter in what we think is possible for ourselves.
Sadly enough.
And you probably have read about this a,
it didn't transpire everywhere.
Monopoly created a special version of monopoly based on this particular episode
of Star Wars and forgot to include the female characters.
Now,
monopoly I should say,
has a fixed this since.
Um,
but it's still remarkable that something like this is still possible.
Now,
let me move on to our last topic and how to design diversity,
which I already announced is a really sore knee topic.
On the one hand,
much evidence suggests stat diverse groups outperform homogenous groups.
But the tricky part is that when you ask people who participated in a diverse
team,
how well they think the team performed and how enjoyable the task was,
they will time and again report that they probably,
the team probably didn't do so well.
And it wasn't really fun because diversity is hard work.
And of course,
because what we're trying to achieve by having diverse perspectives represented
in a group is exactly what makes people uncomfortable.
You want people to disagree.
We don't want people to fall into group think and just run in the same direction
because somebody said a,
what's the right answer?
And that makes diversity so hard.
So let me give you kind of a few thoughts.
So some is VT,
old news.
Yes,
critical mass does matter.
It does matter whether you're the only one of x,
the only woman,
the only Swiss German economist,
whatever it might be in a team,
it does matter.
You will be turned into a token and you are also much more likely to perceive
yourself as a token.
So having three of x in a team or roughly 30% in many cases is helpful.
But diversity is not just a numbers game.
And I just want to end by highlighting this.
It goes beyond numbers.
Numbers themselves are very helpful and important,
but we have to think about the decision rules and rules of engagement,
uh,
on our teams as well.
And here's one that was a personal surprise to me and that is political sub
correctness.
So I came from Switzerland to the US.
And the Germanic culture is not a culture known for PC.
And I have to tell you that initially I am used all my stereotypes about
Americans thinking,
Oh God,
this is a very superficial,
this whole PC thing.
Now it turns out really serious research suggests it's actually working.
Why,
let me show you a picture here and ask you the following question.
Where would you be more likely to drop a piece of paper probably on the dirty
beach.
So what we see or what we hear signals something about the prevalent norms and
the question for us,
they're for Villiers,
where would we,
where would we be more likely to drop a dirty joke,
not in a PC environment.
So norms can matter.
And how we present information can matter.
And I have,
um,
one of my favorite slides up here,
which shows that,
you know,
on the happy note learning really is possible.
On a sad note,
we have been using this pyramid for decades in this country to help us make more
educated food choices.
Now here is the deep insights.
We do not eat off pyramids.
This is the new image.
It's a plate.
And I'm sure it resonates with you that immediately you can see whether you eat
too much dairy,
too little dairy,
too little protein,
too much protein,
things of that sort.
All of us probably have some reflection,
some reaction to what they see.
For me,
it's a dairy,
dairy lover,
and I'm still disputing the fact that this is so small.
But anyway,
so here's some how we've used this information to reshape some of the norms in
the gender diversity space.
This is a cover from the UK.
Some of you might be familiar that the U K decided in 2011 to increase gender
diversity on corporate boards to 25% by 2015 without the introduction of quotas,
but instead by relying on behavioral insights.
So we've worked a bit with the various groups involved.
Specifically for us,
it was Vince cable,
the secretary of business.
Uh,
in thinking about how behavioral insights could be helpful,
and this is the brochure that they show to us.
In 2013 when we were first approached showing that 17% of board members were
female.
Here's what concerned us.
Sometimes descriptive norms can turn into prescriptive norms,
not just describing how the world is,
but suggesting how the world should be.
And so we were nervous about this depiction of reality because it might suggest
to us that yes,
the right thing to do is to have small fraction of women on boards.
So we designed the cover page and uh,
focused instead on the organization which already have diverse sports,
the same sample,
the 100 biggest companies that put you on a hundred companies in the UK.
But what we were focusing on was who and what fraction of the $100 companies are
already diverse.
And at that time,
that was 94% signaling that the thing to do was to join the club and be diverse.
So if you're interested in learning more about some of these findings,
we've created an online platform,
the gender action portal,
uh,
which is searchable,
where people can find more,
find out more about what works to close gender gaps in economic opportunity,
but also in health education and political participation.
I'm happy to take questions,
comments,
thoughts?
Hi.
Hi,
my name is Marta.
I have a question about,
I just want to hear your thoughts on motherhood because I'd been reading a lot
about how,
you know,
we can do a lot up front to recruit more women,
but there's a lot of bias associated with women once they get to a point where
they're considering having children.
Um,
I myself have not,
and thinking I might not want children,
which is a whole nother conversation about the reactions that I get for that.
But there's an immediate assumption right after a woman gets married,
I feel even here,
um,
that their productivity might decrease because their priorities will change.
And I'm trying to reconcile that with women.
I hear saying,
in fact their priorities do change along with fathers who say the same.
So just love to hear your thoughts on that.
Thank you for the question.
Um,
in fact,
I'm going to draw on some of your own research at Google.
So as you can tell,
I mean,
I,
uh,
am a fan,
lost the LaBox book work rules.
And when Google realized that,
uh,
women were more likely to leave than men,
they analyze the data and the data told them that it wasn't actually women who
are more likely to quit,
but it was young mothers and Google being Google then could increase it's
parental leave and uh,
both in fact,
not just for mothers but also for fathers,
young fathers.
And now apparently it doesn't have a gender gap in a likelihood of leaving
anymore.
So that's um,
I think the power of data and the power of something that is more clearly more
than behavioral design and that is kind of taking into consideration that people
have lives out of outside of their jobs and that we have to accommodate those
lives and those needs,
um,
to make sure that the employees can also thrive in our organizations.
So parental leave policies,
again,
this is beyond cable design decisions,
just not economists speaking based on economic evidence on that a parental leave
policies are quite possibly the most powerful tool we can use to decrease the
motherhood penalty that you allude to.
Now what?
Of course it doesn't correct for our devices that we have the stereotypes that
go with seeing,
for example,
a pregnant woman.
And there isn't a lot of research suggesting that there is something like a
motherhood penalty and that yes,
um,
modern stew earn less than fathers and that in fact the correlation goes the
other way around.
That man tend to make more money,
money when they have children and women tend to make less money when they have
children.
Um,
so I do think the,
the bias is the stereotypes are absolutely,
you know,
well and alive.
And by becoming aware of them,
we won't solve the problem.
But in fact,
I plop Google,
I'm not just saying this year,
I say this in my book also,
I applaud Google for going to the data and really trying to understand what is
happening here and then trying to fix what's actually broken.
So generally,
by the way,
a bigger answer to your question is I am,
I'm skeptical that we will ever be able to overcome our biases as human beings
until we see something different.
So,
for example,
let me around a following thought experiment with you.
Maybe orchestras could the major orchestras in this country.
Cool.
Did we move the curtains now?
Because now that we have almost 40% fee and musicians,
maybe we're starting to associate building on to India evidence,
we're starting to associate,
um,
playing music with women and maybe we don't need the curtains anymore.
Now of course I might be wrong,
right?
This is an experiment yet to be run.
But the evidence that we have so far from an particular,
from India with numbers have changed very quickly because of quo does.
Makes me kind of optimistic that when we see the change,
eventually our mindsets can change.
But I don't think by just being aware,
for example,
that there's a motherhood penalty,
we will perceive mother's differently.
Okay.
Oh No.
One more question.
I can't
Catlett only one question happened here,
um,
about the resume bias.
Uh,
that's pretty well known by now.
Plenty of research on that,
especially with both minorities and women.
But,
um,
my understanding is that there's,
there may be similar bias at the interview stage.
And I was reading an article recently about this and apparently there are
companies now that have sprung up to essentially what they do is to do
screening,
but the way they do screening is they give tests that are designed by the hiring
companies and submit the test results to the company and how,
you know,
without any sort of identifying information with them at all and have the
company's first select candidates that they will interview based only on these
test scores.
And then,
um,
apparently according to what I've read,
this tends to also increase the number of women who eventually get hired because
they don't get screened out at an individual interview stage.
And I,
I wish I remembered more of the details of this,
but I'm wondering what you know or think about.
Yes.
This part of it.
Thank you for the question.
I discussed it at great length in the book.
So,
uh,
absolutely.
Um,
the best predictor of future performance and hats,
again,
not rocket science,
is a work sample test.
So when I hired a research assistant that is not very hard for me.
I can give the person a problem,
ask her to do some data analysis,
run some regressions,
write a short report,
and that's a very good predictor of how well the person is going to perform in
the future.
So a work sample test,
he is the best predictor of future performance.
Full Stop.
One of the worst predictors of future performance are unstructured interviews.
Now,
social scientists,
it's actually not new.
No social scientists have been trying to convince the world that unstructured
interviews are bad predictors of future performance for about 50 years.
So being a behavioral scientist,
I actually don't believe that we'll ever people to give up to interviews,
right?
If 50 years each year we are bad communicators in that might be part of it.
Who knows?
But in any case,
I think this,
we're clinging to interviews and even so I started as academic dean of the
Kennedy School for a few years.
I could not imagine hiring a new faculty member without having talked to them.
So I'm totally guilty of that.
At least I use a structured interview.
So that's why I,
my recommendation would be to combine a work sample test with a structured
interview,
which at least is using a structure process and structured interviews are
actually better,
better able to predict future performance.
Um,
but there are companies now and it's super exciting.
Super interesting to see which do away with resumes completely and instead just
to the work sample tests and it's exactly right.
That's exactly right.
Um,
and then only the very last stage of the process,
they actually see people face to face interview the last 10 or the last five and
but using structured structured protocols.
So I think it's very,
very appealing to think,
um,
of the kinds of tests that you could use.
And uh,
two in fact predict future performance.
Here's one thing when the interview is helpful and that is of course you will
probably sink that right now.
And you're of course right in an interview,
we're not just evaluating a job candidate,
but we're also telling something about our companies or our organizations,
right?
So it's sounds a bit of a sales pitch on my end and that's okay.
As long as you're done with your evaluations,
right at the end.
I'm very comfortable and I did that too.
I'm very comfortable to have an unstructured part and talk about synchronized
swimming and talk about the teaching load at Harvard and you know,
our wonderful students or whatever else it might be.
Um,
that is different from me trying to evaluate a job candidate.
just one more thing and then I'm going to call it the next question.
But,
um,
the best evidence if you need evidence on kind of,
you know,
what interviews made the best,
but one of the one that kind of drove the point home to me was a bit of an
eyeopener comes out of Texas.
So a few years back,
the state of Texas realized that didn't have enough physicians.
And so what they did is they went back to the medical schools and told them that
they have to increase the intake of new students by about a quarter.
So this one medical school,
um,
that analyze the data at Houston had already admitted 150 students,
the top ranked students and now may at the very late in the academic year had to
go back to the rejected applicants and admit 50 of the initially rejected
people.
In fact,
the people that have to admit at that point we're ranked between 700 and 800.
These are basically all people who nobody else wanted.
And they thought initially of course catastrophe,
catastrophe,
you know,
now anyway,
they will never make it here.
And um,
but if of course it's turned out into being a quasi experiment,
allowing research to follow the 150 top ranked students and to 50 lowly ranked
students over many years to see where did that initial evaluation system
correlated in any way we've had to perform your medical school and post medical
school.
You know,
I wouldn't tell you of course,
if you know where I'm going,
correlation nonexistent.
It doesn't matter whether you were initially 788 or number two,
you did quite equally as well in medical school and post medical school.
So something clearly was wrong with the evaluation system.
So then they're going back to delegation system,
which heavily,
it turns out it was heavily based on interviews,
about a third of the final score was due to more quantitative measures such as
previous grades,
letters of recommendation,
a work experience before you went to medical school.
And two thirds were based on these interviews.
So if you take out to into your score,
then at least you get a little bit of a correlation between the quantitative
scores and future performance.
But to interview was just making things worse.
Um,
in fact,
the,
uh,
the authors of the research paper can call it at the end that a better mechanism
would be to just use a lottery rather than interviews.
So that's just one study.
There's many of those,
but truly unstructured interviews are kind of viewed discredited in a social
science.
Yes,
please.
Well,
I'd like to start with saying that I do a lot of interviewing myself and if we
could talk at Google into,
you know,
dropping interviews,
I'd be,
I'd be thrilled.
Um,
so there's,
uh,
what are the issues that we have in,
in the hiring women for engineering?
Is the,
is the pipeline,
I'm mean,
we're here right now.
Just the resumes coming in.
It's,
it's,
you know,
male,
female movement.
You know,
it's just very hard.
So I'm wondering if you thought for me,
you know,
behavioral psychology standpoint of how do we address that?
Is there something that we can do to persuade all the young women out there that
the computers are fun?
It's a good job as well,
you know,
join us,
come,
come on in.
The water's fine.
Yes.
Yeah,
no,
absolutely.
Um,
and pipeline issues are real.
and I,
you know,
again,
what the,
when I work with organizations,
I quite literally look at,
you know,
what is the pipeline and when do we start to see,
for example,
on the proportional or over proportional promotions,
which then would suggest that maybe there's some bias going on,
but the pay managers are real.
So last week I spoke at two different conferences.
One was a women in stem and that I was actually a,
a chair.
The panel and we had a number of very interesting,
I'm NGLs and startups,
uh,
working with schools and the kind of things I learned there were,
you know,
astonishing to me as well.
That Algebra tool is not taught at most of our public schools in the United
States that,
uh,
most of our teachers are not equipped to teach Algebra tool.
Um,
so many of the,
so first of all,
you know,
many of our students aren't even equipped at the kind of tools that companies
like Google for example,
needs.
That doesn't explain the gender bias here,
but just more generally.
And so what they're doing is they go into school and many of them versions off
providing kind of help to teachers.
So one project was a science from scientists.
I've just getting scientists into schools,
helping teachers,
teaching science.
Many of them were focused on a girls,
uh,
primarily or exclusively.
I'm also providing mentoring,
sponsorship support systems.
Um,
so that's kind of one thing.
The other conference I just spoke with wasn't Saturday.
It was the women in math at Harvard.
And again,
I learned some interesting things and some are kind of VD ripe for some design
changes.
Um,
some of you might have studied math and mathematics and we'll remember that it's
super competitive to get into the best schools like Harvard or Mit.
Um,
apparently you need to participate in lots of competitions already in high
school.
And it turns out that,
uh,
match research suggests that women do not like competitions.
It's a bit similar to,
you know,
willingness to take risk,
uh,
self confidence.
We also tend to,
we tend to want our work to be evaluated for what it is and not necessarily a
participant in hyper competitive environments.
So lots of m research suggesting that that might actually
yeah,
decreased the Laika that a women will choose those kinds of fields.
So I think it's a combination off enabling boys and girls to do the work.
And it hit me hard teachers to teach the kinds of subjects of providing role
models,
mentorship,
same sex teachers,
a lots of evidence suggesting that same six teachers in particular counter
stereotypical subjects matter.
So this of course for girls would be math and science for boys reading and
writing.
So equally as serious.
Um,
so all of those,
um,
kind of we need,
we need to attack.
Um,
and then think about kind of 50 signs that people are in,
such as,
you know,
the hypercompetition that seems to be a parent in mathematics and do,
I did ask sweetie necessary for people to succeed and become good
mathematicians.
Okay.
Hi.
We were taught,
we were lucky enough to have Jean and David's talk at our headquarters in
mountain view a couple of weeks back.
That all right.
You know,
where I'm going to sack her,
her take on how the media can help make the world better.
Bay.
You know,
you talked about changing out the portraits in the hallway and she's talking
about can we change the things that we see in movies and TV to help solve this
issue.
Um,
I was curious what your thoughts on that.
I know whether you,
yeah.
Um,
so she and I were at the same place in California in October,
spoke at the same place and um,
uh,
she might have told you that as well as some research it,
I wasn't actually aware of that.
When we represent groups of people,
then the typical croup is like one third or a quarter female and two thirds or
three quarters male.
Um,
so yes,
I'm completely agree with her.
Um,
I think the evidence on seeing is believing is really overwhelming and the kinds
of book goes back to the early question.
Also the kinds of books that our kids read,
the kind of cartoons that they watch.
And that's why ray,
I mean was,
you know,
half a joke,
but taf serious.
It does matter what we see,
what people were,
how we,
you know,
we present different characters,
whether on the screen or in a book or on our walls.
So I,
yes,
I am completely,
completely aligned with her.
Yeah.
Okay.
I just got the time.
Um,
I think behalf to wrap up.
Thank you very much.